the snow just keeps on coming in the
Austrian resort of leh where three
skiers died at the weekend authorities
are battling to clear roads over the
border in Germany guests at a hotel had
a lucky escape when an avalanche slammed
into the building and in Bosnia three
people died when a coach slid off a
snow-covered Road across Central and
Eastern Europe the snow has broken
records and has plenty more to come
Steve rudram had been hoping to ski in
the Austrian Tyrol but feared he'd be
snowed in so retreated back down the
mountain so the snow banks in the town
are between three and four meters and
I've never seen snow accumulated like
that before but it's probably up to
about two meters on some of the route
clock and they're having to use the dump
truck to remove the snow from town now
because it's diploma snow on the ground
that the local authorities can't cope
with it anymore just piling it up high
according to meteorologists at Reading
University the snow has come from wet
Atlantic air that's been pushed into the
Arctic by a high pressure zone over the
UK before heading down to the Alps but
we could soon be feeling the effects too
over the next few weeks what we're
looking at seeing is the Jetstream
weaken and shift further south and that
leaves us prone to outbreaks of cold air
coming in from the continents as we then
lie on the cold Hollywood side of the
jet stream does it necessarily mean
we're going to see the same kind of
snowfalls as they've had in the
continent they absolutely not it would
be impossible to see that level of
snowfall in this country because we just
don't have the mountains for it in
Germany the Army has been called in to
clear roofs that could collapse from the
weight of snow another blizzard will
sweep through the continent over the
next day or two with up to one and a
half metres of snow expected in parts of
Switzerland the weather is locked in a
pattern and the Alps are taking the
brunt Thomas More Sky News